all right i got a hypothetical last one
okay so apparently this girl's dad
subscribed to her only fans geez up okay
that led me to the question is it better
if you if you had a daughter that had an
only fans
would you rather be super successful or
like a huge failure and then no one
wants it oh that's tough failure
failure yeah you'd want it to be failure
but
i mean if it's successful you're just
she's just going down this path forever
yeah what incentive does she have to get
out of it also i'm definitely going to
subscribe to my daughter's only fans
what
son she's not going to post crazy [ __ ]
if i'm a subscriber no yes she is
it's only she's going to post crazy [ __ ]
now you're looking at your daughter like
she's going to post crazy [ __ ] knowing
her dad is looking at me naked
yes yeah
you're the weird one who's subscribed to
a [ __ ] only face or you making only
fancy compete with her
and just shut her down or that that
would be my best you gotta shut her down
you wanna sign up to your daughter's own
yeah you tell her you want to have his
only fans i'm signing up huh you wanna
have this only fans i'm signing up okay
and then what if she blocks you
you're gonna ask for my dummy accounts
yes yeah it'll be definitely
she thinks about that she when she
posing listen she's what 20 years old
you don't think i'm looking at your
daughter's little [ __ ]
come on
don't do that [ __ ] if she's just regular
but if she's the only fan that's that
[ __ ] for the street correct correct
that puts you for the streets correct
that's the thing if my daughter and only
fans y'all can look at her [ __ ] on only
fans yeah
if she owned only fans i don't believe
she will be i want you to tell my
daughter you're looking because you
failed that's not her fault that's your
fault exactly you dumb fails your
daughter why am i looking at your
daughter's [ __ ] hole spread
oh my god why because of you i'm angry
at you i'm saying you pictures like why
did you do this that i'm doing damage
control i'm telling her hey look look
bro you can't look at me
you can't let it get there because i'm
gonna have to step in too when i when
i'm after i look through all them
pictures i'm go i'm gonna call you what
the [ __ ] well why are you assuming it's
like dumb hardcore what if it's just
feet second what if it's just like a
little feature same same do same bro
that [ __ ] is off it's all come on you
can't be you can't be allowing that [ __ ]
bro come on i don't know if i say the
same tell her put them feeds on
instagram i look on instagram
instagram is for the people bro yeah
instagram's for the people yeah that's
that's gotta be the rule if you're a dad
your daughter's only fans don't be upset
that i'm looking at it be upset that you
don't [ __ ] up to the point where your
daughters aren't only fans
right or wrong i agree angry at me
angry at me i'm still
it's still weird you're gonna sign up
for your daughter's only fans that's
strange bro why support
policing yeah but you're supervision
you're supporting her and now she's
going to keep doing that [ __ ]
supervision i kind of know what he's
saying he's like yo hey he's going to
text her like hey i just subscribed and
then she's going to be like
i got to get a different one i got to
make a new one i got i got to duck this
yeah it's like when your parents come to
your show or whatever you want to you
know adjust the jokes some i don't but
some people do
you know or your wife or something
doubles down
[Laughter]
my mom just [ __ ] crying out of
embarrassment
poor one
but yeah i don't know do you adjust your
[ __ ] if your girls uh folks are there or
something girls folks i probably would
definitely not wife
you got to be able to laugh at this yeah
but uh parents i had my parents have
been in one show and i didn't cuss i was
like
yeah but i was like i i yeah i did it at
a show you didn't cuz i didn't cuss but
it was a show where like i could
probably should probably not cuss it was
like i was hosting something
and i was like y'all can come to this
because i know i'm going to be clean on
this
other than that don't come was it easy
to be clean yeah because my jokes aren't
that raunchy so i just don't cuss it's
like being around a kid you just watch
what you say
in terms of like cussing did they watch
bring back a poo
my dad said he watched it but my my mom
probably watched it but didn't tell me
because i'm like don't watch it really
probably see it yeah why hilarious
i don't know i don't it's like a big
there's a big respect thing with indians
where it's like i have to be a certain
way around my elders so i don't want you
to see me how i am with everybody else
i know you're going to know that i do it
like i'm telling you what it is but i
don't want you to see it hmm like i
don't cuss around my parents to this day
really no i don't they know i do it
they'll hear me doing it with other
people but like if my parents are in the
room i'm not cussing
it's a different thing meanwhile you're
signing up to your daughter's only fan
now yeah what happened to them
he wants to support his kids yeah his
parents didn't watch his [ __ ]
also what i jerk off to is my business
guys
this guy's wild bro this guy's wild dude
crazy he's going to jerk off to his own
daughter and only fans oh why are you
seeing what's only her content maybe
it's a collab oh man somebody just
scissoring that up
dude the the flagrant three podcast with
my dog
yo that'd be a little crazy bro i'm not
gonna lie that'd be a little crazy